they make it their business to mind your
business party buses let passengers gets
lost while professional drivers tool
them around safely and yet Bloomington
Illinois has recently banned booze on
the buses and then there's this I am
very pleased to have with me today
actress and humanitarian Halle Berry
Halle Berry and Jennifer Gardner helped
pass a new California law that cracks
down an aggressive paparazzi who
photographed the children of celebrities
the photog snap away without parental
permission they risk up to a year in
jail the law will also grant special
protection to kids of politicians police
officers and judges I'm here to speak on
the behalf of all the other children who
face harassment for no other reason than
their parents profession but this time
on any of the months 4th birthday you'll
find the nation's top nanny just outside
of Hollywood just monitors for keywords
where if a student is considering
harming themselves harming someone else
the glendale unified school district has
begun monitoring the social media
activity of 14,000 middle and high
school students the district officials
aren't just interested in violence
they're also looking for hate speech
fake IDs obscenities sexual harassment
bullying drug use and more as a parent I
am okay with that I know it feels a
little big brother-ish but we go to so
many extremes to keep our kids safe
officials received daily reports on
students public postings from geo
listening the contractor hired to keep
tabs on the kitters in the future looks
bright for the company which expects to
be monitoring students in three thousand
schools worldwide by the end of the year
follow nanny the month on twitter submit
your nanny nominees and click here to
watch another episode
I was three but now i'm off for years
old